welcome everyone for the Tuesday evening
lecture and today I'm going to show you
my game from a 2014 US Championship and
this was one of my best US Championships
this one in 2017 the 20 2014 was very
different I started with 4 draws in a
row and it seems like I couldn't get
going
4 draws in a row and you know obviously
people ahead of me I think Alex
Linderman had like three and a half out
of four or something so he was having a
great tournament and then something
changed and I won't fall in row so it's
pretty rare I don't know if I can
remember last few years if anybody won't
fall in row in the US Championship maybe
so and then playing great chess and then
this is one of the winds so this is
round 7 so before that I defeated
Grandmaster Karev and I defeated
Grandmaster Ramirez and now I defeated
Grandmaster Robson and day after I was
defeated Edinburgh so at that time with
four wins you know I was already one
point ahead of the field with three
rounds to go so so this was an
interesting game so I'm playing gray and
with many many games always very
interesting games and the first shocker
g4 from Robson this came as a big
surprise but he had a second helping
giving this tournament redeemed
grandmasters tinker Alice so and I don't
know what the prep was they just
completely surprised me with this well
at least I wasn't too worried about
because I'm a d4 plash so you know I
know how to play against d4 so I was
sort of happy because there were some
problems with the e4 I remember when I
was preparing against race so so d5 c-46
g3 and he goes straight to the cut alone
so I don't take a toll on myself so
that's why probably he choose to play
this this way and term so be sure before
check but what I have going for me is
that my opponent is very new to this
opening so it's not quite for me to even
though years it's probably a great
preparation but he's not familiar with
the ideas and what he can try to do so
that's why I'm trying to surprise him as
well so I played this Bishop before
check we should be seven so far we're
moving pretty fast this is theory any
place Bishop f4 activating his Bishop
and now Knight h5 because the bishop is
very strong on this diagonal okay Bishop
is very very powerful here so that's why
I'm trying to go nightly try to force
him to go back but he goes back to c1
because if you see the bishop is on d2
so he goes to see one because nine wants
to have the d2 school for his Knight and
he goes here so I sort of pushed the
bishop back but that way he gets the
night on the two so very interesting
play by white as well so p6 so with
black when you're leading the tournament
you just want to be solid and wait for
your opportunities I don't remember how
Robson was doing but he will he was
probably in the middle of the pack so he
was he needed to try a hard to win I
mean we're round 7 getting closer to
that finish line you know with eleven
rounds total rook c8 once again I'm just
playing solid c5 when you do all this
prep work b6 Bishop e7 rook c8 what is
the next logical move to play r-truth
c5 right get the bishop open get the
lines open and
now I open up the diagonal for the
bishop he plays couldn't be won okay now
my queen is little bit vulnerable in
some lines I was experiencing some
issues because my queen is on a line of
the rook and this was the problem that I
had so takes takes so okay queen v1
takes because I thought okay you know I
did all this work to get the bishop
there and you know I gotta open up the
diagonal I don't want to have this
bishop blocked so that was the reason I
took now it takes back for the night and
Bishop before I think this makes sense
because the attack is queen with the
temple but now he goes Queen a1 and now
he has some battery pressure and here I
realize I have to take on d4 because he
is threatening to take so that's why I
wanted to take he takes back with the
bishop now go Queen c7 okay if I have
two moves Queen B seven rook F did I'm
very happy you know this would be my
next two moves and I'm very very happy
with this okay Queen b7 Rock f th bishop
h3 did have a surprise from Robson I
mean he's trying to complicate the
methods but wish page three feels bit
off the tough but you see what he's
trying to do he's trying to play very
very concrete rook f d8 logical play
rock c1 attacking the Queen will be
served
okay if he doesn't do much what am I
going to do now capture an f3 capture
capture with a queen now he goes 95
activating his night and attacking my
bishop now what should I do here
I don't want to lose my life square
bishop right well [ __ ] page five
beat feels bit artificial you know f3h
six he can maybe sacrifice only six yeah
I don't want to human Bishop d5 d6 I
played Bishop d5 I didn't want to do
them because 93 he can get another
temple on me so I just drop back when
she okay he was trying to make some
sacrifices work you know so I had to be
kind of careful but only six on f7 I
mean he's obviously that's what he's
aiming for you know you know I go squid
me one look at that move now he's
gearing up you know well now he wants to
take on f6 you know he has he has a
concrete threat you know to take on f6
and Queen h7 and if I take back with the
night he has additional squares 95 to
come to so I had to be kind of careful
here so the next move is very important
here
Knight f8 what they say what did saying
night on a faith there is never made
right and here is no difference and here
actually I'm defending h7 superbly and
defending on top of that defending is
six as well and asking him to give me
the bishop okay and asking him for that
bishop as well got it
multi-purpose move just tuck it it in
attacked it attack - that's what you got
to do so that's a kind of move this one
I want to show you this game because 9fa
this kind of moves don't think a lot of
people have the idea oh you bring the
knight back itches retreating you know
it's playing passive no but here it's
very concrete look I defend I think he
probably missed this move or at least he
underestimate because now he's gonna be
down upon actually because now I think
there are some problems the bishop is
hanging and there are no sacrifices with
knight on a fade there is never mate or
anything you know it's very hard to
checkmate somebody when here's a knight
on their faith I don't know if you've
thought about it if you've thought about
it or experienced that with a knight on
the field it's very very hard to do that
rook FD one age six
well now I'm safe so I'm pushing him
back and he doesn't have any sacrifices
so he drops back and I'm gonna just play
greedy and take the pond
yes but okay to win this position it's
it's not an easy task you know because
he has two bishops he my life's words
are weak so it was some serious
technique I had to put here to win this
because I'm only slightly better here
and he's got an active night too so I
had to come here because if I drop on g2
he's got Bishop g2 he probably thought
he is okay here but you know when you're
in good form you find the best moves and
that's what's happening I was just you
know I had the momentum when I was
getting this wins one after another and
that's playing good moves and here again
once again I made a move that is very
logical and strong block to play
how should I try to by the way he's
threatening to play knight c6 he is
threatening to take 96 so and then
attack my bishop attack on a7
so what is your suggestion okay
that is perfect trading the night nice
in general this applies to many many
correct decisions if opponent has an
active piece centralizing the middle of
the board almost always a good idea for
you to do what trade him off okay so
remember that almost always that would
be your best idea okay to trade him off
trade okay get rid of him okay
that's what you want to do okay trade
him off to be able to get a position
it's easier to play to when when the
last piece is on the board it's easier
did you realize that when when you're
under some pressure you liquidate pieces
a little bit less pieces less things to
worry about okay Bishop III my opponent
plate and now in ideal world I want to
do another trade here and which trade is
that bishops if I write an ideal where I
want to trade those bishops off the
board and I'm doing really really well
here and let's see I didn't play Bishop
c5 here because rook c1 and then you're
getting pinned up a little bit here
tangled up I did the same thing from
this direction though and now it is h3
attacking my Queen Queen h5
they should before he refuses he refuses
to trade the business he knows he is
gonna be in trouble if you doubt that
now I pin him and I got a some serious
pin on him because you know he cannot
just move the bishop because I take on
the one so now I'm gonna induce another
weakness and now this is weakening his
dark squares with the pawn on g3 he has
very good chances with the pawn you know
he has very good drawing chances but
once he's played g4 that is gonna be a
huge square at some point for my knight
imagine Knight lens on f4 that is gonna
be very very nice so he plays queen I
play Queen h4 I know for a moment it
looks my pits are off but they're gonna
come back into the game
there should be five trade of course you
don't want to blunder a move Bishop g3
get your queen trapped here huh so it
was time to come back we should be seven
now the threat is Bishop c5 so you pay
Queen e2 Bishop c5 if you place Bishop
d3 what do you do capture because you
got the absolute pin on him
so Bishop b8 attacking my pawn
a five just make sure pans are guarded
Queen f3 Queen d8 first I want to get
rid of this Bishop this Bishop is in my
territory Cushing away right
go away go away now look at that go away
again getting the momentum and now Queen
belongs worth like a rook right on a
second rack putting pressure on f2
putting pressure on a2 and now if they
say foreign finally the moment has
arrived the moment has arrived to play
this move and establish the domination
of those there you go and how are we
going to accomplish that absolutely now
you can tell now you can tell ya block
is very close to a victory because
bishops are coming off extra pawn in the
pocket and a good squares for the knight
on f4 and f5
things are looking very promising here
Bishop d6 Queen is technically this is
winning this shouldn't be but he tried
to you know put some problems he's a
tough defender Knight f4 and now which
move you really want to play in this
position
well I I want to play g5 at some point
but I want to do it now because he has
Queen f6 so first I go Queen d1
threating a very powerful 92 so he
checks I come up here he goes here and
now since this screen can I come to f6
what do we do fix it fix it okay you're
fixing it now Queenie fourth in this
position it's possible not easy as well
now you want to get into the
complications King g2 Knight has to go
to g5 and some well the queen is here so
yeah yeah no no I think that might have
been winning too but I just wanted to
just keep the dumb h3 is my pawn anyway
it's not going anywhere so I just want
to keep the domination see I can take
now if I want upon its check so I go
here first if he checks then I go King
g7 so it was Queen e3
and now in this position you know what
you need to do you got to get the same
position with opponents move and what do
we call that sook sook sook sir Bank we
call it yeah yeah that's called sook
saman okay
there is a Suk's bunk so how are we
gonna do that okay excuse me you need to
get make a move that it's his turn
without but you make a move so he
doesn't have a check
no no not pawns pawns are weakening the
position
no no Queen is perfect don't don't touch
the Queen though don't touch the night
don't touch the pawns now
please find a move for white hey you
think only f6 amounts in the books right
queen f1 losing the bishop and they made
22 takes the pawn that's what he did
well no he played before actually well
Queen takes b6 first I take on h3 and
then I go back to a4 I take also on g4
before I could do other things but let
me just take this I didn't want to give
him any chances so maybe five there you
go here I don't want to lose any pawns
you know so I just go here for check
kick and this is important now I just go
nice III it's very powerful move because
threat is now 94 and the threat is now
Knight d1 so it goes Bishop e2
requesting that
check and our knight goes back where mmm
yes because you want to go ninety-two
now and checkmate on G one when you have
the night only two you have the mating
threat on g1 so you have to go here
threatened Quincy one mate and now widen
it at six
you don't need f6 just think think you
have a clear plan clear path to the
victory he for past pants everybody they
meant to be for what pushed okay pushed
I'm ready to push push if he takes Queen
g1 mate so he played h4 sure he goes
here now now he's telling Queen f6 check
and now how many pounds I'm up two
pounds right so time to do what let's
get rid of this T of course you resign
but why you want to give up no need to
get fancy Archer there's no need for
that I just realized they probably had
other ways to win - okay and then I just
pushed the a pawn yeah what's the
question
yeah because if it takes Turks Turks
push
push push okay got it
excellent so that's very important to
see how to play this opening let's
review this game make sure you
understand the opening ideas okay so so
again the first move was was surprised
when he played this move exclusively at
that time at least it was
so I played d5 so we have which opening
everybody Catalan Catalan check
because I forced a bishop on B to D to
wear it blocks the night you know so the
bishop is considered misplaced here yeah
bishop in which opening it very hardly
you can find any opening okay in a group
it's probably one of the only openings
here that you actually put it there
can you see 295 I went back and what's
the plan here
yeah but he's you know it's not expected
that you know he will play for a drop
plus there's no point yeah you know it's
us championship you know to come here to
make draws you know it's not like you
know last round oh well he has a white
pieces and he's he's a fighter he's
gonna play for a win a minute it's they
we just repeat because it's just well we
did it we all actually we only repeat we
only repeated one time we didn't even
repeat it because he went back to c1 I
mean if he I knew and already he
wouldn't like make a drone first of all
but I mean if you repeated it I do have
an option but I do have an option if you
know play a five here if I really want
to I mean it's not like I have to take a
draw I'm not in a situation without for
stated but I can play a five and we play
chess you know okay we play chess it's a
stone wall you know type of position you
know I play five and put the night only
four it's good to go to playable
position
okay so now I have 692 p6 it should be
seven Roxie eight and c5 once you get in
c5 like this you can be safe that you
have equalized the game okay because
when you put your pieces on good squares
you make the break in the center where
things are not hanging you're doing all
right takes it's possible but it really
depends what kind of position and you
know but in general where you don't have
any like look my position has no
weaknesses I mean no structural or any
kind of weaknesses I have here
see and this was very important and of
course the most important move of the
game night f8 everybody always use that
square when you're under any type of
pressure use that night to tuck it in
okay on a fade okay use that night got
it okay perfect okay I have a couple of
medium difficulty puzzles for you to
work on now so we will do a few of those
right now okay okay black to play here
very nice pin and also the knight on f2
is hanging as well luck to play and win
okay we have one student who has it
let's give a chance to others few
minutes
so first we have to understand what is
white trying to do white has a pressure
on f7 with the bishop with the rope so
he wants to take it so yeah but he just
goes King g3 yeah
King takes f2 taking your knight engage
in the game yeah pony
yeah just takes one f7 check and then
takes them night you can take this with
a check and then take the rock take
knight King gay treat rook takes rook
who else who else has obsessed Caleb
anybody else is it Samsung
now ideas you got the guys who mentioned
that personal somebody mentioned the
first great intuition Samsung I caleb
what's the next move first move rook h1
right everybody got will catch one so
now if this bishop is not here then you
can trade right so what kind of idea is
out there to do a deflection track right
Caleb check if takes you take the rook
so if it goes here he defends it but he
goes here it's not over yet you gotta
continue well I can't trade in quite yet
Oh chief why Kim Jiwan
welltake okay but this slowly you're
gonna win
sure slowly black will win this because
of the rook black will win this yes
slowly so black is up exchange so that's
why okay in original position you wrap a
whole rope but you were in big trouble
you ignite your bishop so that's why you
have to be a little bit careful and find
the only saving idea check here and
check all right let's do another one
not easier not easy
Kayla probably knows this one
he's doing his tactics and he just had a
great tournament in the cold where
Kansas Columbia 21 22 getting there
getting there yeah alright I don't have
to take right away by the way you might
do it where I don't have to enough a
blood stain you know our tune
we'll have a b5 Brooke takes everybody
got that
RJ nice work sir all the way you know
his calculation is excellent so takes
here winning at night so if he goes here
winning the pawn pushing the pawn and
winning if he goes here are two on the
car that's it nice work by Arjun okay
then we're gonna do one a hard one okay
yeah those are rare medium medium
difficulties okay white to play and draw
you need to play like a strong
grandmaster from Russia at QF the
problem we're having here is the queen
is under attack
okay the queen is under attack and
basically you move the Queen just takes
the knight okay
so I do plan win sorry why do plan draw
Bishop takes f8
yes but we only you give up the rook you
give up a rope and now I trade quince
and you know I mean I'm up a fish to
puns so do you know this one - you have
to play like a strong Grandmaster of Tom
if all right let's give you a couple of
minutes to work on this one it's very
nice very very nice the long calculation
and this one needed okay long
calculation needed for this one to win
sorry for draw yeah
draw is like a win here because you know
it's I'm pretty sure black played rookie
five thinking you know he's probably
gonna clear okay faith and I'm just
gonna win this game but things are not
as easy now as they appear to be
sometimes wrong calculation then for
sure for sure
okay that's a confidence and guys that's
a good confidence of a player right
there
well it's you got you gotta have the
entire thing King h6 King GA you cannot
just perpetual with the rook you need to
have yeah
all right younger June ok game you go
slow this is okay just one second let me
catch up here okay
if you taking a four key check team
effort solved correctly
everybody nicely done very very nicely
done okay
so because you have to realize like in
this position when you when you're in
trouble when you're losing you just have
to figure out what to do you have to
look for opportunities to escape okay
escape to a draw so here is your
opportunity to do that you know because
everything else loses it's very possible
black mistis because it's very hard to
see and I can tell you by by looking at
the position they're probably
approaching first time control here very
likely they approaching the first time
control so that's why it's important to
stay sharp tactically and always
calculate okay who would have seen a
move like rook Queen takes e5 with rook
f8 in a real game with three minutes
ticking on the clock huh yeah so that's
why you have to do more and more
exercises like this okay so you get
stronger so your visualization is
stronger so you can see these things
okay so it's it's very very important to
do that that's why this this exercises
are great from that perspective because
here the Queen moves you just lose the
night
I mean rug affair we discuss it's just
pretty and in fact now I'm thinking
maybe even this is a move here
because what to do now
then Queenie six just take the knife
next can't play which mode
well that's check quite chick always you
have to look for the in-between checks
remember okay always have to look for
those swooshing socks
yeah so that's why you have to go with
Queen takes if I first once again again
it takes what did we do Chuck he goes
here shock Chaka sure he has to go here
check again and now you would stop see
most people would stop right here they
would say oh it doesn't work they would
look at the rook g6 and they realize
it's losing most people I assure you
they will stop here but not you you will
go a move deeper a move deeper to see it
in that move is rook h7 double
exclamation mark if he captures you've
got the knight f8 so he has to do it
here check and that's raw got it perfect
so guys gotta continue more and Thursday
I have two lectures we're going to do
more game on more games and more
difficult puzzles like this once okay so
looking forward seeing you on Thursday
thank you for coming
[Music]